legends up tomorrow hi legends zombie
Comic Con to you all yes yeah so
veterans at this point what is your
favorite and least favorite thing about
comic-con woo not eating lunch okay for
the rocking boats too much when they're
in the yard
sometimes it gets it gets you a good
shot guard yacht life is hard not see
we're just like don't more to the dock
you know answering questions not as
exciting no best part I think is seeing
old friends single trans like getting to
like fangirl out on the other shows fans
in real life like not just social media
yeah like snubbing celebrities that's
meeting Ted Danson yes me too
I've got to give you guys props though
cuz I just I just said before we got
started there are a lot of superhero
casts here but you are the only ones who
defeated you're a big bad by joining
together into a big blue cuddly Bebo um
Legends is so great because you guys are
so meta you're so out there I've got to
know can we expect it could you be even
crazier in this next season
oh they learned it has to be fortunately
we sort of set a course that we can um
go back and think there's a quiet sort
of you know like the BBC drama at this
point yeah
well season three ended with you know a
reappearance of Constantine coming back
and telling everyone that you have
accidentally opened up a whole chamber
and now all these monsters are coming so
where do we go from here and how dark
are these monsters well we
we go lots of places because you know
the these monsters as Constantine warned
us monsters creatures from myth legend
fairy tale
they've all been spat out across the
time line and you know it becomes this
lovable groups job to clean up their
mess and baguette tag these you know
magical fugitives is what we're calling
them and yet it's going to take us to a
lot of fun time periods and we're gonna
face creatures that are familiar in a
way but of course have a fun legend spin
on it before the season started I'm
curious to know as a cast did you kind
of put in your request to the writers
room of saying like it'd be really cool
if we go to this era or maybe this
location we're not allowed to talk to
them I'm used to call episode would be
fun we've used in an episode we they get
to singing every day I'm game flash did
everything that we might wanna legends
the miners are taking requests their
request music - we have some surprising
music that's my episode off Katie and
Jess we saw some pretty adorable moments
between these two lovely ladies last
year what can you tease that's moving
ahead for them because I should know
that's means a good thing the poor sale
mean is going away if you didn't get on
it it's really nice and it's the first
time Sara's had like you know something
really real and it's good for her and I
think it's good for both of them and
we're on a good path maybe I'm excited
to see you because in the season 3
finale it sounded like Amaya was like
I'm out she is so I am playing Charlie
who is one of the magical fugitives who
sneaks up on the legends and she's a bit
of a rebel without a cause wild child
punk rock kid who they stumble upon and
they have to decide whether they're
gonna keep her or put her back like they
know they should and why is she here and
what does Han personal motive
[Laughter]
you think nate is going to react
essentially seeing a doppelganger of his
TBD I mean I can't really decide that
that's a bill job but um I think it's
present
all right the the breakups around its in
but in the beginning of the seasons now
that the website is officially up how
can fans connect with you even more and
what do you hope that they learn from qi
thority so all of us have written
articles and we read everyone's articles
so we've already gotten a hundred
submissions and we just released it on
Monday and so you know check out the
website read some articles send in your
own story have something to share our
brand is gonna write one about raising a
son and it's it's really yeah it's it's
been awesome like you really feel super
connected with everybody and everyone's
got such wonderful stories to shell
share that's so helpful for other women
and thank you me hopefully making
anything happen um and thank you so much
legends for coming I just want to see if
you can tell me it one tease about this
next season that fans don't already know
the only thing I can say about the first
episode is it's gonna be horny
do you get what that means when you see
it you had mentioned Fairy Tail so I'm
thinking it's more than just beauty
thorn situation not one cast this whole
thing is it horny more than our it's
always legendary guys thanks
[Applause]